hey this is presh talwalkar
this problem was suggested to me by
email by arbitrary renaissance who also
thoughtfully provided the background to
the problem
very often when people suggest problems
to me i reply back and i asked for the
context
where was the problem asked and what
tools were expected to be used to solve
the problem
this problem was asked in the fall 2016
online math olympiad
this is a math contest for high
schoolers that's offered in the fall in
the spring
teams of up to four people
answer 30 questions in 11 days
only a basic four function calculator is
allowed
each question is worth one point
and the average score for this test was
nine
so even these very talented high school
students who took the test
we're only able to solve on average
about one-third of the questions
now the very top score was 29
which means this person answered almost
all the questions which is truly
incredible because there are fairly
difficult questions
i have reworded problem 16 from the test
as follows
at the end of day zero
six magical seeds are planted
on each day following each seed has a
chance to magically transform into an
apple tree with the probability of one
half
once a seed transforms into an apple
tree it stays an apple tree and survives
indefinitely
what is the expected number of days
until all six seeds have become apple
trees
write your answer as a fraction m over n
where m and n are relatively prime
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so let's get started by translating the
problem into some of the mathematical
details
so the first sentence just tells us that
there are six seeds that we need to
consider
the next sentence tells us the
transition probability
the probability that each seed turns
into a tree on day i equals one half
the third sentence tells us
just the detail we need to know for the
problem that once
a seed is a tree it stays a tree forever
so we can disregard this sentence we'll
just keep that into account as we do the
calculation
finally we need to know the expected
number of days until all six seeds are
trees so we want to figure out the
expectation of the number of days until
we have six trees
in this video i'll present two different
solutions i'll first go over the
official solution which starts from the
definition of expected value
then i'll present my own solution which
uses a trick to solve in simple
equations these are formally known as
markup chains and recurrence relations
but you don't need to know the jargon to
use this method
in fact if you've been watching my
videos you may already know this method
so let's go through these two different
solution methods
the official solution starts out as
follows
we'll write n to equal the number of
days until there are six trees
we want to calculate e of n
by the definition of expected value e of
n equals one times the probability n
equals one plus two times the
probability n equals two plus three
times the probability n equals 3 and so
on
the official solution then has the very
next line
e of n equals the probability that n is
greater than or equal to 1 plus the
probability and is greater than or equal
to 2 plus the probability n is greater
than or equal to 3 and so on
now i've taken several probability
courses and i work on many probability
puzzles but this form of the expected
value is not something i've seen but
apparently in contest mathematics it
must be very common because they just
went ahead and said this is the second
line of the proof
but where does it come from
so let's derive this luckily arbitrary
renaissance sent me a more detailed
solution write up which showed where
this came from and it's actually an
interesting little derivation
so the trick is to rewrite the
expectation as follows
let's consider the second term 2 times
the probability n equals 2.
we can write this in a stacked form of
two terms of the probability n equals 2.
the next term 3 times the probability n
equals 3 we can write this in stacked
form as three terms of the probability n
equals three
now notice the pattern will continue
the next term will have four terms that
are stacked up
the term after that will have five terms
and so on each subsequent term will have
one more stack term
so now we have the expectation as sort
of a triangular series of summations
the very first summation will be the
probability n equals 1 plus the
probability n equals 2 plus the
probability n equals 3 and so on and
notice this is equal to the probability
n is greater than or equal to one
what's the second line
well this starts out at n equals two so
it will be the probability n is greater
than or equal to two
the third line will be the probability n
is greater than or equal to three and
now you'll see where the pattern comes
from
so this is why the
expectation of n is equal to the
probability that n is greater than or
equal to one plus the probability n is
greater than or equal to 2 and so on
so how do we go from here
well we need to figure out each of these
terms
so we'll first deduce that the
probability that n is greater than or
equal to k will equal one minus the
probability n is less than or equal to k
minus one this is by the complement rule
of probability
this is because it will be easier to
deal with the probability that n is less
than or equal to k minus one
this is the probability that all six
seeds become trees by day k minus one
so in order to figure this out we'll
also consider the complement probability
the probability that a seed is not a
tree by day k minus one will equal one
half to the power of k minus one
this is because on each of the k days
there's a one half chance that the seed
does not transform in the tree on that
day so we need to multiply one half
k minus one times
therefore the probability of seed is a
tree by day k minus one will be the
complement one minus this
and now we need to consider six
different trees so we need to take this
particular probability and have a
product across six different seeds
because each seed turning into a tree is
an independent event
so the probability that all six seeds
are trees by day k minus one will be one
minus
one half to the power of k minus one
and we want this entire thing to be
raised to the power of six
so we now know the probability that n is
less than or equal to k minus one
and we need to know one minus this
so how can we simplify from here
well notice we have a binomial
so we can expand this using the binomial
theorem
now you have to be very careful when
doing this so i'll show you the full
derivation of all the steps
we'll first use the binomial theorem
we have the binomial coefficient times
one raised to some power times the other
term negative one half to the power of k
minus 1 raised to 6 minus that power
so the first thing we can do is all of
these powers of 1 1 to any power will be
equal to 1 so these terms will vanish
we can then simplify the binomial
coefficients
now we have negative one half
to the power of k minus one
being raised to another power
so we can then simplify this as follows
we're going to have an alternating sum
and the power it's being raised to can
go in the denominator
so this will be the expanded form
of
this
term and now we need to take one minus
this expanded form
so the very first term is one so that'll
vanish and then we're taking one minus
this so we'll then reverse the signs on
each of the term so we've now figured
out the probability that n is greater
than or equal to k is equal to the
following six terms
we can further more simplify the
denominators because we can raise 2 to
whatever power was in the denominator
so now how do we figure out the expected
value of n
well the expected value of n is equal to
the sum of these probabilities going
from one to infinity
now notice each of these terms is a
geometric series that's summed from k
going from one to infinity
so we can sum each of these six terms
independently
and we'll use the formula that the sum
of the geometric series is the first
term divided by the quantity 1 minus the
common ratio
so the expected value of n is the sum
across 1 to infinity
of the following six terms where each
term is a geometric series
so we can evaluate the first term using
the formula for the sum of the geometric
series
and then we can just do this term by
term
so you have to be careful and diligent
to just make sure that you get each of
these sums correctly and finally you now
need to evaluate this sum and you may
need to make sure to get the fraction
correct because you need to leave it as
a fraction
where the numerator and denominator are
relatively prime so if you do that you
end up with the answer
of 7 880 divided by 1953
and this is approximately 4.03 days
so that's the official solution and the
answer so it takes about four days
for all six seeds to become trees
so this is one way to solve the problem
i thought about it in a different way
i thought about it using recurrence
relations
so i thought about it as follows let's
write e sub k to be the expected number
of days to get six trees if there are
already k trees
what we want to solve is e sub zero
so let's think about it backwards let's
imagine we already have six trees
in that case it's not going to take us
any more days to get to six trees e6 is
equal to zero
but what if there were one fewer trees
what if there were just five trees how
many days would it take us to get to six
trees
well if we have five trees that means
there's one more seed that needs to
transform
so after one day
there are two possible things that could
happen to that seed
with probability one half that last seed
becomes the sixth tree
so our waiting time is then e6
and with probability one-half that seed
remains dormant so we stay at five trees
but in that case the expected waiting
time will still be e5
so we can write an equation
that e5 is equal to one more day
plus the two possibilities that can
happen with probability of one-half
we saw that e6 is equal to zero
so we have an equation that e5 is equal
to one plus one half e5
therefore e5 is equal to two so if we
have five trees it takes about two days
to get to six trees
and that makes sense
so now let's go one more step backwards
what is e4
if we have four trees that means there
are two more seeds so after one day what
could happen to those two seeds
well with probability one fourth both of
the seeds will transform to make six
trees
with probability two fourths
exactly one of the seeds will transform
so we have
five trees
and then the expected waiting time will
be the expected waiting time from having
five trees e5
finally with probability one fourth
the two seeds will not transform we'll
stay at four trees
and
the expected waiting time will still be
e4
so we get the following equation e4 is
equal to one more day
plus the following three possibilities
now we substitute in the values for e6
and e5
and then we can solve this equation for
e4
we get e4 is equal to eight thirds
now we can continue
what is e3
well if we have three trees that means
there are three more seeds so after one
day
there are four possible outcomes it's as
if we are flipping three coins and
counting the number of heads we can
either have zero heads one heads two
heads or three heads
so we end up with a distribution that's
very much like flipping a coin
three times
and the probabilities will be 1 8 3 8 3
8 and 1 8
either to get to six trees five trees
four trees or three trees
so we can write out the equation for e3
and since we've solved for e6 e5 and e4
we then have an equation that's just in
the one variable e3
so we can solve that e3 is equal to 22
over 7.
now from here we continue
we can figure out e2 because that means
we have two trees which means there are
four more seeds so after one day
we have a distribution of five possible
outcomes
as if we were flipping four coins and
counting the number of heads
so i've written out the details in this
particular video but i'm just going to
skip ahead in the narration
we're going to end up with the following
equation for e2
we can substitute in our values that
we've already solved previously
and then we can get that e2 is equal to
368 over 105.
now we need to continue this until we
get to e0
so let me just quickly go ahead to the
details of e1
we end up with the following equation
and we're going to substitute in our
previous values and solve that e1 equals
2470 over 651
so this finally gets us to what we want
which is e0
so if we have zero trees that means we
have all six seeds then after one day we
have to consider all the possible
outcomes we can get anywhere from six
trees to staying at zero trees
so we end up with the following equation
we've already solved for all the
previous values
so we have only an equation in e zero
which we can then solve that e zero is
equal to 7880
divided by 1953 and that's again
approximately 4.03 days
so there are two different ways of going
at this problem
in this solution method you have the
added advantage
that you get to actually figure out the
expected number of days when you have
three trees or four trees
so did you figure out this problem
and which method did you use to figure
it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
linked in the video description you can
also support me on patreon
and you can catch me on social media
either at mindyourdecisions or at
preshtalwalker depending on the site